c---span her first television interview
since joining the High Court this week
our cameras follow Justice Ginsburg on a
visit to her High School in Brooklyn
America and the courts this evening at
7:00 Eastern Time on our companion
Network c-span c-span 'he's live
coverage of the lincoln-douglas debate
reenactments begins August 20th and
continues through October 15th
each of the seven host cities in
Illinois is planning local activities to
highlight these historic debates you're
invited to attend each of the
reenactments August 20th in Ottawa
August 27th in Freeport September 17th
in Jonesboro September 18th in
Charleston October 8th in Galesburg
October 9th in Quincy and October 15th
in Alton to find out more about the
local events planned for the historic
Lincoln Douglas debate reenactments in
Illinois call toll free 1-800-789-7895
believe we had been
and the chair will recognize mr. lazy Oh
mr. color welcome back from Long Island
my home base hope you enjoyed the visit
I'd get there every weekend good I want
to begin as a prosecutor telling you how
much I appreciate your role as the
attorney for Bill Clinton and understand
your desire to protect him but I do have
some concerns about a chronology of
events and what that means with respect
to your attempts to give him what you
call a heads up for example according to
my notes and they might be incorrect I
invite you to correct them if they're if
they're incorrect on September 27th we
had bill roll a of RTC telling Gene
Hanson of the referral on the 29th
Hansen briefs Nussbaum and Sloan with
respect to the referral later that day
you'd see the Nussbaum or Sloan briefs
Lindsay on the 30th Hanson call Sloan
later on the 30th Sloan tells Lindsay
again and several days later sometime on
October 4th or 5th Lindsay briefs the
president on a flight with respect to
some of these matters including the
possibility as published in some
newspaper articles that Jim guy Tucker
the governor of Arkansas was a possible
target of the probe
now sometime later about two days later
October 6th Jim guy Tucker this
potential target meets with mr. Clinton
as well as with this good friend from
Arkansas and his chief of staff Mack
McLarty and webster hubbell and of
course this is a very significant
meeting if it relates back to your
desire to keep the president pristine
out of trouble by giving them the
so-called heads-up my first question is
did the president speak to Jim guy
Tucker about the matters that we now
know as whitewater let me follow up with
that and ask you a second question if I
might given our time constraints did you
ask the president whether he had such a
conversation with Jim guy Tucker I am
informed that the president and Jim guy
Tucker did not discuss any whitewater
manners or anything related to mr. Hale
or these other cases during their
meeting I would like to correct some
other things in the account that you
just gave me so you do that if you'll
just indulge me for a moment would you
explain to me how you are how you were
informed of that I was informed of that
by mr. Bruce Lindsey who has told that
by the president so just to clarify that
point you never asked the president
directly whether he had any
conversations regarding whitewater with
a potential target Jim guy Tucker that
is correct
it is also correct that when mr. Lindsay
gave the president the information that
these criminal referrals had been made
he did not know that Jim guy Tucker was
involved in them he did not learn that
according to mr. Lindsay and he will be
here before you until I believe the 7th
day after the meeting and all of this
was simply from press stories he by that
time as I understand it the the the
press had already reported that Jim guy
Tucker might be a possible target and I
just want to clarify this again that
Lindsey did get a briefing based on
summaries and not based on press stories
with respect to the referral
he got briefing on the fourth which he
does not recall mentioning Jim guy
Tucker he learned from press reports on
the seventh after this meeting well it
looked like I said one less but he did
not tells the president my time is only
reference to Jim guy Tucker doesn't this
obliterate the whole rationale for
giving the so-called heads up which we
used to call a tip-off when I was a
prosecutor if you don't ask the
president if you don't protect him from
a potential target when clearly there's
information surrounding Jim guys later
you're going press through press stories
or through the official summaries that
he was the official targeting mother
Johanna tell the president what you
don't know how do you know until the day
after about Jim guy Tucker in any event
there was no conversation in the meeting
having to do with whitewater and that's
another way a president continued don't
know that perfect mister sanders you
never asked that question
Thank You mr. chairman um let me just
make a few brief points and then maybe
raise an issue that is of concern to me
and I don't believe it has been
discussed yet today a number one let me
just reiterate I think there is concern
legitimate concern that we're not
getting into all kinds of areas that the
public is interested in but I would
simply remind members of the committee
that the scope of this hearing is
limited by House Resolution 394 which
was supported by the overwhelming
majority of the members of the house and
let me quote why probably all of us
voted for that resolution and that was
to make sure that this hearing quote
would not interfere with the ongoing
investigation of Special Counsel Robert
V Fisk and the quote in other words
there
is more to happen we are going to learn
more but I think we can all agree we
don't want to interfere with the
investigation of mr. Fiske a second
point that has been made very important
basic point is the special independent
counsel mr. Fiske Republican has
concluded his investigation of forces
death and the issue of the contacts
between the White House the Treasury in
the RTC yes included forces force that
committed suicide and also and I quote
that the evidence is insufficient to
establish that anyone within the White
House or the Department of Treasury
acted with the intent to gruffly
influence an RTC investigation and the
quote the third point that I think we
are concerned about today and that
indicates that they were in fact as I
understand that over 40 contacts between
the White House staff the Treasury and
the RTC staff and I think the bottom
line is that the American people do want
to make certain the charges against
Madison guaranty were treated by the RTC
in exactly the same ways that they would
be treated if that Bank had no
connection to a man who was elected
president R therefore I think this
hearing is appropriate and I think that
it is useful although mr. Fiske has
concluded that there is no basis for
criminal prosecution it is absolutely
appropriate that we learn as much as we
can from you in terms of those
discussions in those contacts you
yourself as I understand it mr. Cutler
have called that quote unquote poor
judgment R and will want to know how we
could prevent such behavior in the
future mr. chairman the issue that I
want to raise and I know that mr. Cutler
is familiar with this issue I don't
believe we've talked about it today and
by no means am I making any derogatory
statements about anybody on this
committee but what concerns me very very
much is there are individuals who on
nationwide radio and television have
disseminated unfounded accusations that
I think nobody on this committee
believes and I'm not suggesting that
anyone does but unfounded accusations
that have gone so far as they even
suggests that the President of the
United States and mrs. Clinton are
involved in murder are involved in
thuggery and
and these are not just little people who
were talking you know some little
splinter group these are people who are
national radio national television
making these things and I am very
concerned about these types of vicious
political attacks not to my mind what
goes on there is not simply an effort to
undermine the presidency of Bill Clinton
that that's what politics is about
that's the game we play but what those
people are doing mr. chairman are really
undermining the faith of the American
people in the democratic process
I disagree I'm an independent I disagree
with mr. Clinton all the time
so did the Republican so do all of us
but if you have people speaking to
millions of Americans who are saying
that the President of the United States
and mrs. Clinton are involved in murder
are involved in arson are involved in
thuggery and that's what millions of
people are hearing what are those people
to believe about the United States
government why should they participate
in the political process why should they
vote this concerns me very much so my my
questions to you mr. Cote are basically
a twofold number one tell us in your
judgment the worst example of what you
refer to as poor judgment there has been
a lot of full judgment what is the worst
and second of all if you can say a word
as to how the white house or how you are
responding or feel about these
outrageous allegations which again I
want to repeat I believe nobody in this
committee believes those are my two
questions well with respect to poor
judgment Mr Sanders as I've said before
second guessing after the event is
always very easy I wasn't there at the
time and I'm sure the people who were
there acted in complete good faith but I
think myself that the question of
whether mr. forced comes from mr. Altman
should recuse himself was a question he
should have decided without consulting
the White House and that it was too bad
that the White House people involved
indicated to him they rather hoped he
wouldn't they had a preference that he
wouldn't they may have had perfectly
good reasons for that my own view is
that once the matter came
it would have been better and I believe
what I would have done at the time is
say go ahead and recuse that given the
political and factual circumstances of
whitewater at the time it would have
been better to recuse and we might not
be here in this hearing today I might
still be practicing war instead with
respect to these attacks on President
and mrs. Clinton they have reached a
level of invective and viciousness if
you'll let me say that that is
unparalleled a new low level is probably
the wrong word a low unparallelled at
least in my experience in the government
that goes all the way back to World War
two I'm sure they've been other periods
in American history when other
presidents have been vilified and we've
survived it but this seems to be very
well financed it's a cottage industry
there are great many people apparently
who would like to bring President
Clinton down who will stop it
practically nothing I talked earlier
about trust
I really deplore the lack of trust of
one party for another of the public for
the president of the press for anyone in
public office today I think we've
reached a low that should make us
ashamed of ourselves it's one thing for
the press and anyone exercising First
Amendment rights to be able to say what
he wants about the administration and
it's good for us but I come back as I
said the other day to mr. Joseph Welch's
statement when he was counsel for the
Secretary of the army dealing with
Senator McCarthy have you no decency and
I think it's something which we should
all remind ourselves thank you time with
the gentleman has expired
grams thank you very much mr. chairman
mr. Cutler of course thank you for
coming today and presenting your
testimony for us so what we have
witnessed today was an impressive
presentation by an impressive
terney about a less impressive client
and unfortunately that client is the
President of the United States and his
administration an administration that he
promised would be the most ethical one
in American history
now for the next two weeks we must try
and determine whether this
administration in holding White House
treasury meetings over the Madison
investigation has met that standard or
has even come close we are not here to
examine the criminality of such actions
that has already been done by the Fiske
investigation we are here to determine
as representatives of the people whether
the White House Treasury contacts
involved unethical or inappropriate
behavior and by the way that is just the
beginning because this hearing
represents only the tip of the
Whitewater iceberg in fact the total
scope of this hearing has already been
mentioned covers less than 5% of the
whole affair and does not allow us to
even begin answering the real questions
surrounding whitewater why did the
Madison guarantee fail at taxpayers
expense and how was the president
involved if we are truly interested in
restoring the people's faith in their
government we must begin by opening up
the Whitewater investigation to full and
public scrutiny and we can take a major
step forward in this respect by again
asking to make the documents on
whitewater public without restrictions
and I also call today for full
disclosure and so should the president
anything less would be a slap in the
face for every taxpayer who paid for the
60 million dollar bail out of Madison
guarantee with their hard-earned money
and it would leave in the minds of the
American people an image of a government
that has grown too arrogant too corrupt
and too out of touch with reality and we
must use these hearings to fully answer
these questions of who told what to whom
and when did they tell them or else the
truth in the faith of the American
people and their government will be the
real casualty of whitewater
with that mr. Cutler I'm interested in
learning how you and your staff read
White House ethic laws and I I'd like to
direct your attention to the chart that
is behind me displaying the White House
ethic rules and for a few questions
first I'd like to ask you do you really
believe what harold ickes and George
Stephanopoulos did by calling Roger
Altman and trying to remove Jay Stevens
the press secretary for President Bush
who dismissed it as quite understandable
but you believed that was their role as
members of the White House staff they
did nothing and nothing happened mr.
Stevens is still there no effort was
made to remove him he is presumably
doing his work also do you think mr.
Cutler that informing the president by a
heads up that criminal referrals had
been made that would involve him and his
wife as witnesses and conceivably as
subjects of the investigation
constitutes a violation of number c2 and
that is giving preferential treatment to
any person I quite firmly believe that
it is not I've said before we have
consulted the office of government
ethics which in informally agrees with
that conclusion and I'm telling you out
of my experience here over many years
this has happened in every
administration Republican and Democratic
because the president is the chief law
enforcement officer and needs to know
even when the Independent Counsel law is
invoked before there's an announcement
to the press that the Attorney General
is seeking the appointment of an
independent counsel once he or she has
made the decision the president is
informed finally you have admitted that
the White House staff and others made
errors of judgment that were regrettable
and that should never have happened you
have said that too many people were
talking to too many people and too many
things doesn't this suggest that the
whole affair is a violation of number C
6 and that is effective adversely
affecting aversive ly the confidence of
the public in the integrity of the
government I don't think you can go to a
coffee shop around the country outside
the Beltway that doesn't believe
whitewater has some well how leads him
down as far as their faith from the guys
if every administration that was a beat
in it was criticizing the presser by the
public for affecting the confidence of
the government if we counted them up
we'd count all 40 or 41 administration's
to date there has never been an
administration which was not attacked in
one way or another for affecting the
confidence of the people in the
government yours or our
I'm talking specifically though about
this language time of the gentleman has
some what exposure you read the language
that way every administration has
violated the standard of ethics they're
not the subject of this here in other
words if you come subject become subject
to criticism you violated the standards
of ethics mr. Kline thank you very much
mr. chairman first of all mr. Cutler I
welcome you as one who has spent my
entire life dealing with facts I have
looked forward to this hearing with a
good deal of anticipation not because I
thought it would be pleasant but simply
because I believe very much in candor in
open government and then openness
wherever possible and I thought that
this hearing would be an opportunity to
get out some additional facts that the
American people would want to know I do
not feel an end innuendo and I don't
think that dealing an innuendo really
gets us very very far I must say that I
came to this hearing with a totally open
mind as to what it would show and
obviously you are only the first witness
there will be other witnesses to follow
but certainly your testimony and the
report that you made and I am very
impressed with the thoroughness of that
report plainly indicates that there is
no criminal wrongdoing that there is no
unethical conduct of any kind and that
all we have are errors in judgment I
thought that some of the many many
questions that I would have heard up
until now from those who are obviously
partisan and obviously adversarial in
their questioning would have revealed
some semblance of fact to contradict the
main thesis of what you have said but I
must say I am deeply disappointed that I
have heard no
facts turning to the question of
mistakes and I think as mr. Lafosse
pointed out so very very well we all
make mistakes some more serious than
others and some mistakes are of such
seriousness that appropriate measures
should be taken and I think you have
taken measures with respect to
correcting those mistakes which are the
result of procedural inadequacies in the
white house office and I think you're to
be commended for that on the you
answered Mr Sanders question as to what
was the most serious you were asked what
were the errors in judgment and the only
one you cited was the one that broke uzl
and I will tell you that I share with
you completely the feeling that it would
have been much better had there been an
immediate riku's 'el by mr. Altmann and
it would have been much better if the
white house and no white house no member
of the white house staff had attempted
to urge him to do otherwise nevertheless
even the riku's all issue is one in
which mister nussbaum acted out of a
sense albeit perhaps misplaced that a
reclusive under these circumstances
would set a precedent that would make it
difficult for other officers to conduct
their duties effectively is that not so
and i wonder if you could elaborate that
is correct and mister nussbaum is coming
here to testify before you I think on
Thursday morning and he makes a very
convincing persuasive good faith
argument for what he is saying and I'm
sure the argument he makes was taken in
perfect good faith
and in any event regardless of whether
he's right or wrong he obviously had a
well-intentioned both of fruit for so
doing as I said I think he believed then
believes now that what he was doing was
serving the interests not just of
President Clinton but the interests of
the country
now I want less you question about the
October 14th meeting which and that
meeting did deal with the subject of the
criminal referrals and it was one of the
many contacts and I think you've noted
that you felt there were far too many
contacts and that's part of the errors
in procedure or judgment that hasn't
this particular one it seems to me was
rather harmless yeah I think it's the
later context referring to the statute
of limitations and the recusal issue
that raised more problems but this was a
a meeting of press people started by
press people to deal with inquiries that
were rolling in at a time when
whitewater was heating up as a public
subject and the White House and the
Treasury were being asked for
information they were being criticized
for not giving information they were
only trying to to alert one another to
the queries they had so they could deal
with and now as I said earlier they're
ironically being accused of having had
an improper meeting in order to get out
more and more accurate information to
the press thank you I believe my time
has expired mr. chairman thank you very
much yes it is mr. Becker's Thank You
chairman of Miss Cutler do you have any
knowledge of any communications between
people at the White House and Paula
Casey concerning Madison guarantee they
said politician Paula Casey all okay see
no I have no knowledge of any such
communications did your investigation
your investigation did you ask whether
there were any communicate
Asians we certainly asked the white
house people whether they had any
communications with anyone in the
Justice Department yes all right and you
were told there were no such
communication so I referred to what we
were told by Mr Nussbaum relating to the
two conversations he had relating I'm
concerning the appointment of an
independent counsel one with mr. Hubbell
who was totally disqualified and the
other with Judge Freeh who was a
personal friend but no knowledge of any
communications concerning Paula case
correct all right second question you
were appointed March 8th I'm my
appointment was announced March 8th and
I began working on March 10th Hart and I
became the I started filling the duties
of the counsel to the president on about
April the 1st but now according to the
ethical standards you were appointed and
conserved for a period of 130 days from
March 8th is that correct well I have
consulted the ethics officer in the
department in the way knows mr. Bokka
system and I am told that according to
the OPM federal personnel manual chapter
735 Appendix C all you need to do is
make a good-faith estimate of the number
of days you were going to work if you
make a good-faith estimate of a hundred
and thirty days and you run over it a
little bit it is not like Cinderella's
coach doesn't turn into a pumpkin all
right let me show that is the advice I
have received from the ethics officers
and our new me interrupt you because I
want I'm going on leave let me just say
the end of center if you got a copy of
that opinion I have cited you to it and
I will supply you with a copy all right
I would point out to you that the Code
of Federal Regulations contains the one
hundred and thirty day restriction and
this is the interpretation of the one
hundred thirty day restriction and I
believe it has never been rescinded
let me ask you this about the ethics
regulations that mr. Graham
referred to all which
deals with giving preferential
treatments any person I think you talked
about important persons compromising the
independence of the impartiality of an
agency or making a government decision
outside the official channel as all as
violations of ethical conduct I you have
you have reviewed the Steiner diary the
two pages we were supplied have you not
yes but have you seen the various
references in there to the White House
pressuring roger altman not to resign
yes and you that is based I take it on
conversations between mr. Altman and mr.
Steiner who recorded his impressions a
week or two after the event both mr.
Altman and mr. Steiner now say there was
no pressure all right and so when he
wrote in his diary that Roger was under
intense pressure from the White House
not to recuse himself he now doesn't is
best to Altman denies that and mr.
Steiner as I understand it as you can
read in this morning's New York Times as
given a different interpretation of it
himself went on the second occasion
about a month later he wrote in the same
diary that the White House was very
negative in the meeting he had with him
about him recusing himself there again
they now have no knowledge of that
you're going to have I assume both mr.
Steiner and mr. Alka and his witnesses
and there's another reference which says
they didn't want him to resign because
they didn't want the RTC operation
turned over to someone they didn't know
do they have they they now deny that
that happened Mr Nussbaum will be here
to tell you exactly what he said and I
related it in my heart prepared you are
aware of the Steiner act the end I am
aware of what is in the Steiner diary
but I am also aware of but what both mr.
Steiner and mr. Altman say about P is if
we take these entries in the diary as
correct that would be a violation of
these ethical I don't
know that it would be but I have not
looked into that matter because well
I've looked into it as far as the White
House people are concerned and I am
satisfied that it did not violate any
government standard of ethics for the
White House people and the office of
government ethics has agreed informally
with that could I just have one
clarification on what you testified as
to you you have stated I think today
that the nonpartisan office of
government ethics has rendered an
opinion saying that the White House
staff are not guilty of any ethical
violations is that right well I can read
it to you precisely but they have
informally concurred in our conclusion
let me just read it to you because and
the reason I say that is I just had a
staff member of called over to a GE and
they say this their study that that it
deals with the Treasury in the RTC and
not with the White House and that it's
not completed and I'm just wondering how
you're getting if the report hadn't been
issued or completed how you're getting a
have not yet expressed an opinion they
had any trade as to whether the Treasury
people did or did not comply with these
ethical standard somewhere the gentleman
has long expired it was made just
complete my answer mr. chairman they did
advise us based on the factual
information we have given them about the
White House people that they concur
informally in our judgment that the
White House people did not involve
violate any of these standards
marshmallon I have what they have said I
have put precisely and I would use a
statement I have read they're saying you
and what time of the gentleman has
expired miss Maloney Thank You mr.
chairman mr. Cutler in today's
Washington Post there's an article on
whitewater entitled questions just kept
growing in the article it mentions mrs.
Hanson and states that she has testified
before congressional investigators that
she was instructed by mr. Altman
to meet with the White House staff and
inform them of the Madison probe mr.
Altmann in this article contradicts her
and states that he made no such
instruction and does not recall ever
having instructed her to do so my
question to you is even if he had made
such an instruction would it have been
illegal I believe the answer to that is
no that while the two of them do differ
in their recollections the meeting it's
the heads up itself was perfectly proper
under these ethical standards that I
have referred to and that is something I
believe in which the author office of
government ethics does agree and it
doesn't matter whether miss Hansen did
it on her own or whether she did it on
mr. Altman's instructions or whether she
told secretary Benson about it or not
are you aware mr. Cutler of anything
unethical or unlawful that George
Stephanopoulos has done I am not aware
of anything unethical or unlawful that
George Stephanopoulos has done I think
is letting off steam to miss mr. Stein
are you aware as many Republicans are
you aware of anything unethical or in
lawful that harold ickes has done no are
you aware of anything unethical or
unlawful that Roger Altman has done no
are you aware of anything unethical or
unlawful that margaret ann williams has
done no are you aware of anything
unethical or unlawful that mark McClarty
is done no are you aware of anything
unethical or and lawful that cliff Sloan
has done no are you aware of anything
unlawful or unethical that bruce lindsay
has done no are you aware of anything
unethical or unlawful that Neil
Eggleston has done no um in mr. Fisk's
examination did mr. Fiske include in his
evaluation testimony from everyone did
it include all of the testimony
well mr. Fisk had both a grand-jury and
interviews and depositions depending on
particular person he wanted to talk to
he had access to everyone he asked to
have access to in the White House no
executive privilege was asserted and he
among others he did depositions of the
president and mrs. Clinton and he stated
that there was nothing illegal is it
fair to conclude that that that none of
the testimony was not proper or illegal
or that he reviewed well of course we
have no access to what was said to mr.
Fisk we never get to see grand jury
records or depositions or anything like
that but mr. Fisk was evidently
satisfied both with the cooperation he'd
received from the White House witnesses
relating to the subject of contact and
came to the conclusion which he is
announced that there would be no basis
for going forward with criminal charges
against anyone thank you very much as he
generally des completed as a gentlelady
completed her I am ok mr. Huffington mr.
Cutler welcome to Whitewater
Thank You Rings to Huffington nice to
see you again
nice to see you making I have a
statement I'll be making then I have a
couple of questions
our system of government is a system of
checks and balances a basic premise to
ensure that the actions of each branch
of government must comply with the
spirit and the letter of both the
Constitution and our body of laws and
when that public trust is broken the
other branches of government have an
unbreakable duty to disclose that
violation and act accordingly
unfortunately these hearings are
deliberately structured and managed to
prevent Congress from carrying out its
constitutional duty to find the truth
the American people have many questions
about the failure of Madison guaranty
Savings and Loan the dubious business
practices of the Whitewater Development
Corporation and the entanglement of
several individuals who now hold senior
positions in this administration and
Americans should be concerned at the
very least this savings and loans
failure cost the American taxpayers tens
of millions of dollars the American
people also have questions about the
handling of key documents and the
trading of confidential information in
the last couple of years as confusing as
this whole issue is the American people
know that a regulatory agency
investigating the dubious business
practices of a failed Savings and Loan
should not provide briefings on the
investigation to individuals implicated
in the investigation this is nothing
more than the Washington political
equivalent of insider trading and it is
just plain wrong we can't get to the
bottom of any of that nearly every stage
of this investigation
from witness interviews to access to
relevant documents has been made more
difficult by those involved indeed the
documents themselves offer a perfect
example of this preoccupation with
covering up events in question
these grossly inadequate documents do
not contain information related to
national security nor do these documents
contain classified information
instead these documents merely provide
the tiniest glimmer of the improper
activities of Staff members in
administration which alleges itself to
have the highest level of ethics ethical
behavior access to these documents has
been difficult at the best of times if
you make it past the armed guard and
pass the confidentiality requirements
you can review all these papers in their
redacted form information has been
liberally removed for no good and the
interview notes that show memories
appear to have become unresponsive to
many important questions it is clear
given the clouding of facts at most
turns that the participants are far more
concerned with the creating the illusion
of cooperation than with the actual
disclosure of the truth what then will
be the result of these hearings these
proceedings are so limited in scope that
not even 5% of the total subject matter
will be considered I'm afraid that
probably very little will actually be
learned except that the American people
will be given a glimpse into the dark
heart of institutionalized Washington
men and women in everyday America will
be reminded once again that the
ever-expanding government in their
nation's capital is not here to serve
them but to serve and protect itself
I suggest that the American people won't
be fooled by the charade this committee
will play over the next few days they
know that the fragile better trust they
have in the federal government has once
again been broken and they're going to
find out who's responsible
mr. Cutler I wanted to ask two questions
were there any meetings between you and
the White House staff with members
and/or staff of this committee in which
discussions included the questions which
member of this committee might ask we
have met with any members of this
committee who would be willing to see us
yes and is it true that a professional
public relations firm was brought in to
prepare you and your office for this
hearing I am not aware of any such event
mr. Huffington the reason I ask is the
Associated Press put out a release to
that effect they may or may not be
correct but you don't believe it is true
well I don't recognize it from what she
was saying was damning good okay my
question would be if there was any group
that then was brought in to from the
outside not from the government to help
you or any other members for this
interview well fair's fair
I assume the Republican members of this
committee have plenty of outside help
in the last question I just want to make
one more statement if I can mr.
Huffington I've been over this matter of
redaction before I can I your attack on
me personally about redaction which is
the only way I can interpret it
surprises and pains me a great deal in
the light of our past relationships I
assure you as I said before it's not
personal art it is not personal it's
just politics gentlemen time has expired
the chair for the record will state that
there are 44 majority and 33 minority
staff members eligible to see all
documents plus all of the 51 members of
this committee 128 persons at all hardly
a road block against full and free
access to information related cost
attention further I've heard repeatedly
about percentages 2% 4% and even 5% and
I have engaged the help of a friend of
mine that studied mathematics with me
and who is now a physics chair and we
have arrived on the basis of the
mathematical approach of Xu Madhav's
formula median averages of eighteen
point seven five percent
sounds like a derivative not five
percent but eighteen point seven five
percent I just thought I'd clarified
mr.chairman parliament required on the
subject of access to information in the
committee staff having full access isn't
your statement today that the redacted
portions of the record may be available
for members of this committee well
everything within the scope has been
provided and I'll remind the gentleman
that when we had BNL we had a document
that was a plain sheet of paper and said
fully redacted and we didn't raise any
issues we just went on what we were able
to get and did get and also witnesses so
I'd say that the gentleman oh if he saw
named anybody on his staff or himself
will realize that if there were any
questions related or if any of the staff
of the full committee had related to me
that in pursuance of their requests that
redacted information was related in an
improper manner we would have pursued it
but at no time was that issue ever
brought up as far as the legitimate
scope and germaneness of the increment
just just as a follow up on that point
mr. chairman I'll be very brief oh
you've been very patient today I
appreciate them you I know I know you
will
I just for the sake of clarity I'm going
to have a staff person deliver directly
to mr. Cutler a request for the redacted
documents I have in question I'll leave
it to you mr. Cutler and an appropriate
staff person if you choose
to respond if you tell me no I live by
that decision but I want to clear it up
what is and what isn't in play chairman
mr. chairman I met your inquiry has
anyone explained the American people
that attacked it means crossed out yeah
it means left forgot hey people are
wondering where attack marries well let
me reply to mr. Baker so mr. Baker you
you and your staff have had that then
I'm sure that this chairman whatever is
the proper answer let's proceed the
chair will recognize mr. Deutsch Thank
You mr. chairman and thank you mr.
Cutler in in 1990 in response to a
comment that US attorneys occasionally
discussed criminal referrals then
attorney general Thornburgh stated that
it was not unusual to discuss them but
that if and I quote if they're a matter
of public knowledge because of
unauthorized disclosure oftentimes in
fairness to the parties you have to deal
with them in terms of the issue of
referrals and knowledge parties involved
if could you follow up both on attorney
general Thornburgh statement as well as
other instances where this would be the
normal procedure by investing Tory
agencies well it is normal procedure I
believe at the RTC and elsewhere not to
make a public announcement of a criminal
referral to the Justice Department in
fairness to the people concerned because
the criminal referral is such a
preliminary stage of what may become a
criminal investigation I'm not familiar
with that particular statement of mr.
Thornberg that you referred to but when
such a referral relates to a high
government official it's quite customary
I believe from my own experience for the
referring agency or the Department of
Justice I the one
to let the president know so that he
will be able to conduct himself
accordingly even when it isn't matter
related to him or one of his close
personal aides that doesn't mean they're
giving him the details they're simply
saying something has just come in and
you should know about it it doesn't mean
that he should interfere with it he
can't he shouldn't interfere with but he
needs to know it and that is the custom
let me just follow up specifically as a
in a sense process case at the end of
September in the beginning of October
did it appear that the press had very
specific information on the referral yes
it was quite clear late in September
that press inquiries were beginning and
at the beginning of October that the
press had received leaks presumably from
someplace in the RTC about the nature of
the criminal referrals and in particular
the incidental references to president
mrs. Clinton and the disclosure was made
mister nussbaum due to concerns over
weeks to the press did the leaks in fact
occur at the same time as the initial
contact by Jean Lewis in the White House
when you say by Jean Louis and the White
House side I don't follow
and the White House at the same time I
don't know of any contact between Jean
Lewis and the White House there was gene
Hanson who had a contact with the White
House is that what you meant mr. doing
it yeah
yesterday night approximately that
within a day or so of the contact yes
and it was concerned that there would be
leaks that led miss Hanson to give
mister nussbaum the heads-up did sue
Schmidt of the Washington Post
specifically called the RT C honor
before September 30th to inquire about
the referral I know that Sue Smith did
require I'll have to check with my
colleagues on whether it was honor
before the 30
we believe it was no later than
September the 30th it may have been
before that and was the purpose of the
meeting on October 14 to discuss a
request for information about the
referral that name acquaintance as
Witten as witnesses it was to discuss
the queries that were pouring in from
the press by that time and how to answer
them and at that point Jeff birth of the
New York Times - Treasury spokesman Jack
Tavor about very specific details of the
referral thereby demonstrating that
there had been a very substantial lead
from the RTC - and you will find all of
that laid out in detail in this
chronological summary attached to my
statement and as I understand that the
referrals were made before the October
14th meeting there had never been any
attempt to stop referrals from being
made and that is correct
in your examination of White House
personality do come across anyone who
had seen either of the criminal
referrals no I'm not seeing them myself
did you come across anyone who destroyed
documents related to either referrals no
did you come across anyone who had
contact either the RTC Treasury or
Justice Department with the intent to
preventing consideration of referrals no
did you come across anyone whose
communication had the effect of
obstructing consideration of either
criminal referral no Thank You mr.
Connor Castle well thank you very much
mr. chairman it's been an interesting
day as we come to the end of the day as
far as Republicans are concerned at
least you concluded that we have 18.75
percent of white water here by a formula
I've used myself mr. chairman from time
to time we've heard 5% and yet we took
the foster suicide and the handling of
the foster papers off so I conclude it's
perhaps one point does 6 7 percent we're
dealing with in any event I think all of
us conclude that it's something less
than the full scope of whatever is
whitewater ms waters made the point that
sort of boring and uninformative and
that's probably as it should be we have
you as a distinguished attorney but just
as you would be turning in a trial for a
criminal defendant or a plaintiff
testifying first and being that sort of
the prosecutor and the judge and
everything else we would expect you to
say the things that you have said let me
ask you this question would you agree
with me that if we really are going to
get whitewater out some day and have the
American people really understand what
we are dealing with should we not at
some point which when it's appropriate
and it's not now when it's appropriate
when mr. Fiske is done etc have a
hearing on the full scope of everything
in whitewater and then we aren't dealing
with 1% or 18% or anything of that
nature if if the public is not bored to
death with whitewater by that time it
could be true if the murky and
complicated facts of a real estate
transaction over 15 years are something
the public is sufficiently interested in
to try to follow and Congress wants to
hold a hearing of course we will get to
the bottom of all of that
and the president and mrs. Clinton will
certainly cooperate mr. Fiske is still
investigating that ministers in addition
as you know may I go on just got he
suggests we haven't really but
unfortunately you've got five hours I've
got three minutes left I suppose um you
concluded that obviously nobody's guilty
of ethical problems as well as the
criminal problems that mr. Fiske found
but this really pertains to the White
House personnel your conclusions now you
said you spoke the lawyers for Altman
Steiner and miss Hanson I think most the
public would think the lawyers speaking
the lawyers isn't a very good conclusion
of whether somebody was unethical or not
nothing you're not a highly a total but
my question to you is you did not really
talk to outside witnesses to do in terms
of beyond the white house in terms of
their ethics or what they may have done
we did talk both to mr. Steiner and to
mr. Altman directly and as I said we
have read the transcripts of the
Treasury Inspector General of all the
other Treasury people and we given them
access to our people but it is not my
mission to pass judgment on them that is
being done by the mr. Benson directed
his Office of Inspector General to find
the facts and then send them over to the
office of government ethics QC you're
working at a slight process now you've
indicated there may be an inappropriate
behavior so they're too many people
talking they're far too many contacts
how many people do you think were
involved in contacts between the White
House Treasury and RT C officials in the
course of all this time and how many
different types of contacts do you think
there were meetings telephone calls well
I have counted up about 12 White House
people six of whom are in the counsel's
office which I think would be perfectly
appropriate and six of whom were outside
the counsel's office as to the number of
contacts you can I have not done an
exact count but they're all the ones we
know about of any significance are
detailed in the chronology and they are
above 20 I would believe they were
probably 30 or in the low there
but I haven't done that I've been I've
been told that there between 40 and 50
count by staff and I don't know this
myself between 40 and 50 contacts among
White House Treasury or DC officials
very involving 40 different officials
that's fairly broad is it not in terms
of at least a whole series of contacts
for firm mr. Castleman I believe there
were too many and that they were not
properly channeled through the lawyers
receives me as you get to more than you
have a greater problem I guess we would
all agree on that you'll all agree to
that the New York Times editorial said
today the one that's been referred to
several times you've probably read
several times the changing stories of
the participants show they were not
innocuous deputy Treasury secretary
roger altman for example was serving as
the acting head of the RTC which is
supposed to be politically independent
of time that he was talking with mrs.
clinton about how to avoid further
investigations the spoil must be lanced
wrote in his diary robert fisk the
independent counsel has concluded that
mr. almond did nothing illegal but that
there could hardly be a clear example of
unethical conflict of interest you
decide that I surveyed oh that's a very
unfair characterization of what mr.
Altman said what mr. Altmann said was
what all you Republicans have said what
mr. leeches said what I think I was
saying from the outside at the time get
an independent counsel appointed that's
what he meant by Lansing the bore and he
wanted to take that initiative from
within the administration are you aware
that in the oversight of the RTC that by
here by the Banking Committee here that
there is a statutory obligation that
they come before us every six months to
report on the progress of the RTC I
think it's been close to 15 16 or more
months perhaps since they have come
before us mr. Altman has this
responsibility he seems to be given a
heads-up criminal referral as far as the
white house is concerned and running his
statutes of limitations on civil actions
etc I have no idea if he's given advice
to this committee that they better do
this or they're in violation of the law
what are your views on that time I
assume as a retired question mr. Gassman
actually was mr. Luke Idris like
you know what he I don't have her mother
gentleman has expired Thank You mr.
chairman mr. Gutierrez Thank You mr.
chairman mr. Colt Coulter for your
testimony I appreciate your candor and I
hope you will not be offended if I
direct on my remarks not to you but to
my colleagues we have heard much today
about Congress's oversight
responsibilities some have suggested
that the majority has abandoned that
important responsibility those comments
are wrong and they ignore the facts our
responsibility is to find the truth to
do it fairly justly and and partially
unfortunately I believe we are lacking
some regard for fairness and
impartiality today many comments and
questions from my colleagues across the
aisle both in the median here today
really surprised me proper oversight is
much more than merely making broad
general accusations and making
complaints regarding the scope of this
hearing in fact I believe we would
benefit by following the advice of mr.
leach himself regarding the scope and
duty of congressional oversight I quote
his suggestions during the BNL hearings
quote there is no right this Congress
shouldn't instigate an inquiry of the
executive branch about issues that
relate beyond policy grounds unquote he
further said it is key that a
distinction be made between misjudgment
and illegal behavior we should remember
mr. leaches words as we proceed with
these hearings and we should further
remember that oversight is certainly not
about ignoring a critical fact the fact
is simple Special Counsel Robert Fisk
has thoroughly investigated all the
contacts that we are addressing today
and found no violations of the law
perhaps that is disappointing to some
people on this panel in fact certain
comments make me believe that some of my
colleagues make mr. Fisk is somehow not
leading an aggressive investigation I
believe the opposite I believe every
person who is concerned about whitewater
should support the work of the Special
Counsel but let me just reiterate I am
not alone in this belief let me read
some words of praise of mr.
and I quote mr. Fiske is a man of
unflinching and uncompromising integrity
he is the kind of person who will bring
out the truth for the American people so
there will be no question as to the
thoroughness and objectivity of this
investigation
who said that some video say it was
Barney Frank for Massachusetts doing the
work of the president wrong
it wasn't Kennedy it wasn't my friend
Bobby Rush from Chicago the person who
said that was mr. D'Amato senator
D'Amato from New York one of the leading
critics of whitewater and President
Clinton who said that what perhaps it's
surprising some people to find out that
he said that isn't to me I believe not
interfering with mr. fix mr. Fiske work
is an appropriate goal and I would think
based on the previous comments of so
many of my colleagues that not
interfering with a special counsel would
be an important goal for them as well
certainly few people exist who wanted
the special counsel appointed more than
my friends on the other side of the
aisle
I think mr. Gingrich of Georgia spoke
for many of them when he said on January
3rd quote if the Clintons are innocent
why don't they go ahead and agree to an
independent counsel to clear their name
well an independent counsel has been
appointed and thus far their names have
been cleared and agreeing not to impede
that important investigation is not
abandoning our oversight
responsibilities it is merely helping to
find the truth a desire to find a way is
why those of us on this side of the
aisle have consistently supported
reauthorization of the Independent
Counsel Act a consistency that cannot be
claimed by many of my colleagues who are
making accusations today against the
president for example and you might like
to hear this mr. Cole mr. McCullum's
memory did not serve him well earlier
today when he said he had not opposed
the Independent Counsel reauthorization
which he did opposed in 1987 and which
he did oppose in committee in 1993 and I
have the committee report in his name is
attached to the minority opinion of that
committee report he voted for it once
Whitewater got a little hot of course I
knew both floor of the House of
Representatives then when it came back
from comfort
where we really vote on something to
make it official he voted against Oh mr.
color your memory wasn't really bad and
I'm sure my distinguished colleagues
memory wasn't that bad either he just
forgot which vote he was talking about
but let me just make it very clear that
it has been said that the
reauthorization of an independent
council is far too costly quote far too
open-ended and far too easily
manipulated into a weapon a political
retribution was it the Democrats who
said that no it's the Republican
minority report in opposing a special
counsel I believe we should listen to
mr. McCullum because those are his words
in the Minority Report and we should
fine and make sure that there isn't
political retribution in these hearings
instead we should follow and allow mr.
Pfister search for the truth and do what
mr. leach has said and I quote a very
honorable man to do a very honorable job
that should be what we should do because
absolutely no official misconduct has
been found us fart and I support that
kind of a process mr. chairman I'm as
the gentleman has expired
here we'll recognize mr. Kane Thank You
mr. chairman
leaving he was incompetent I'm the final
republican you'll have to endure so I
guess the worst part of your day is over
I would just like to say the outset that
Senator D'Amato is a constituent of mine
and he will be delighted when I tell him
the mr. Gutierrez is using him as
reliable sources certainly we've come a
long way in bipartisanship now uh I just
wish we would show some consistency mr.
Cutler uh I am the final person on this
side I would like to make a series of
evidentiary points I give a speech and
allow you to respond at the end because
of time constraint one the other day and
Face the Nation you said you've
concluded that as far as the White House
people are concerned there were no
violations of any ethical legal
standards mr. Cutler I would think that
if you look at mr. Altman's diary and if
you accept it as being valid for January
fourth of January 11th well he says that
the first lady's chief of staff told him
that the first lady is paralyzed because
of white water that he said her strong
inference was that the White House was
trying to negotiate the scope of the
Independent Counsel with Reno so unless
the Attorney General and also the first
lady has said quote that she doesn't
want the counsel poking into twenty
years of
public public life in Arkansas if that
is a valid entry by mr. Altman and that
was a contemporaneous recollection of
what happened not three months later but
as of that date then I would say that
both Ms Williams and indeed the first
lady may have been involved in conduct
which is not ethical because they were
directly interfering certainly the first
lady would been interfering as farming
to restrict the council and Ms Williams
was interfering and telling us mr.
Altman secondly as I understand mr.
Cutler you were the one who made miss
Williams aware of the diary entry by mr.
Altman and subsequent to that mr. Altman
delivered to miss Williams a seal
envelope marked personal and
confidential which she threw away now I
would think that since you are the White
House Counsel she's in the White House
that that considering the fact that
she's been before a grand jury the fact
that she's retained counsel the fact
that she's coming before this committee
in this ongoing investigation by mr.
Fiske and will be construed as
disruption of evidence I think that she
should have made that known to you what
the whole lawyer or to the special
prosecutor rather than just destroy it
as she admits she did thirdly I've been
hearing from the other side numerous
comments about how criminal referrals
are somehow trivial was thousands of
them every year I would refer you mr.
Cutler mr. Altman gave a written
statement in response interrogatories
after his February 25th hearing and he
said quote it is the policy of the
artsy's RTC not to disclose criminal
referrals or information about their
preparation the disclosure of any
information concerning a criminal
referral may serve to alert a suspect
that an investigation may be pending and
enable a suspect to conceal or destroy
evidence conceal or dissipate the crime
fabricate evidence or otherwise impede
the investigation in addition to that
again to show what I think is the real
significance of a criminal referral I
have a July 14th July 13th memo from the
council in the RTC well he specifically
says the unauthorized disclosure of a
criminal referral or the receipt of that
referral would be a criminal act as
defined in the Privacy Act at five us a
section 552 a one my final point
Cutler that'll be glad to have you
respond this is a follow-up on what mr.
Lazio had said before on September 29th
of 10 to 30th of last year the White
House counsel's office told Bruce
Lindsay about the criminal referrals on
October 4th or 5th mr. Lindsay told
President Clinton of the criminal
referrals these referrals mentioned the
Clintons they mentioned Clinton 1984
campaign and they mentioned Arkansas
Governor Jim guy Tucker as a possible
target two days later the president met
alone with Governor Tucker in the White
House now this two days before he's told
that Governor Tucker could be a target
of the investigation yet two days after
that he meets with governor Tucker now
what kind of a heads-up was that how was
he being protected or shielded when in
fact he met with a person who could be a
target of a criminal investigation let
me start with your last question I've
been through this before with mr. Lazio
but mr. Lindsey did not hear anything
about Jim guy Tucker being referred to
in these referrals until the 7th after
this meeting when he heard press reports
to that effect Kadesh mr. Carla are you
told by mr. Lindsey that he was not told
at the September 29th Oh mr. Lindsey and
you will have it yes and he told you
what I have it here moves over yes and
do veneno far as I know there was no
reference to Jim gaat occur in any of
the contacts that had occurred up to
that time between the White House and
the Treasury other than what was in
press reports mr. Lindsey did not inform
the president of any reference to Jim
guy Tucker because he didn't know about
it but in any event when the meeting
occurred the president and Jim guy
Tucker his successor in office you do
see the governor of the state when he
comes never discussed this issue going
to your next question you just go back
to then the whole purpose of this
referral did he serve a purpose our and
the chair will say that we have about
or minute